Are you feeling overwhelmed with the workload around the house?
Are the kids reluctant to even do their share?
Oh, hey mom!
Please clean your room.
Looking for an easy way to motivate your family to help out with the household chores?
Hey mom, I'm going out soon.
What's for dinner?
Well, don't worry.
You and your family need to try the website FamilyChores.com.
It is a website that encourages a great work ethic within the home at any age.
Kids become eager to help out because they earn points for the chores they do,...
...and can cash them in for rewards like toys, books and electronics directly from the site.
Or they can save them and build up their bank accounts.
With Family Chores, your kids develop a sense of pride and a can-do attitude...
...all while contributing to the daily family chores in the household.
Try FamilyChores.com today.